Okay people, we are almost there. I know this is the this is very long even for me
I'm recording it right, but I still I don't know. I won't open the tiktok and scroll
So it's pretty long though, but okay overall after all these lectures and fancy stuff
You can still ask me. What am what am I even doing here? Anyway?
What's going on? So and I will try to answer this question right now. So
Look at this as the experiential
experimental learning
During your final project you will learn how to use Google Cloud platform the Linux terminal
subnets
So what is there?
How the data flows how the machine learning models really deployed into the production
You will work on building and iteratively improving your models
Because to make the good model with the good
With a yeah with a good performance in the production from the first attempt. It's pretty tough because usually on the
in the enterprise
data science flow
There is some steps to test your model in production and see the real-life metrics not only the kind of the synthetic data on
static training data sets
So and you yeah, you will deploy model and take a look on the model using our live leaderboards
as well as
Yeah, you will have hands-on experience with cloud as I mentioned and live AI system
Okay, so yeah here how it works behind the scenes
You need to train you will mimic the minor behavior in other words data scientist
Behavior, but you will not only be the data scientist
You will also be the MLOps engineer and the data engineer in the very end
You will track your model how it perform
what is what model tracks good what model tracks bad and
So yeah, this is why
we look on this opportunity as the
very huge advantage of yours because you are not only you will not only touch all these tools
but as well as you will
Understand how to use it into the production because prior to that you were working with a static
call-up with a stress with a static training and validation data with the
static and
Building stone models and their performance. Well now you have an opportunity to take a look how it works in the real world
So our problem statement what we're even trying to do we trying to
Predict let me show you on the I will pull the website screw this presentation. I will pull the website
So what's going on here this example, right? We're trying to predict the
Energy demand in the New England including connect you could Massachusetts and other places
Yeah, we have as an input we have them let me let me show you give me a second
So this is our database. This is the core where the all the data leaves
So you have we have here training data
With specific format that miners are used to create a training data set for you
It's had the timestamp the total load in the specific time and all the weather data right here
So these for example 9 now it's 9
28 p.m. And this data is the most recent actual data that was
It's uploading here automatically using the IPI of the ICO
New England of the
Energy
energy load data
So and it's got data engineered into the specific format
Second thing is the test data set this data set is in future. It lives in future all this weather information
It's forecasted. So is the forecasted
Weather information that we are pulling from
Iowa yeah, I own environmental
Data government platform. So this platform allows us to pull
government ready
Weather forecast
Okay. So yeah our I think it should be now pretty clear. What is our training data?
It's the data from the past and our test data when your minor is deployed in production
Minor receives minor receives rows from the test data from the future to make a prediction
But if you using the leg features, right the leg features are looking in the past
They will still use the
Past total demand from the training data set that are in the past
Okay
Speaking about the leaderboard itself
We have here several options 1 hour 6 hours 24 hours 7 days and 30 days. I
Think the most representative one is the 24 hours here on the right. You can see the accumulated
blockchain
Scores that your minor received. So for example minor number 6 for the last 24 hours
It has the oh, I'm minor number 4
so I'm pretty proud with my num with my minor right now and
For the last 24 hours
The accumulation score accumulated score was this number for example minor number 17 is on the seventh place is professor Dave's
Model and it's also doing like pretty fine. The next leaderboard. This one is the leaderboard that shows information in each
point of time so each five minutes it's
Updating and you can see here for example minor number 54 made the best
prediction in the
last specific data point
So but for the 24 last 24 hours minor 54
Wasn't that good?
Where it is? I can't find it. So it's not even top 10
But so this is why this leaderboard is less represent
Representative because some model can make just
Random prediction and it could be right in the specific time but on the
Several hours period the accumulated result is worse than
worse than that
Okay, how to use this plot here you also can filter on the six days on the days and hours
For example, you can see here on the 30 days
Let's take a look on the 30 days that there are clear patterns in the energy demand data
But also here the most represent a representative one is 24 hours. Let me take my minor
This is my minor number four and as we can see here, it's not doing
Great, but in general it can sometimes at this sometimes catch the general pattern
Let's take a look on minor number six. Oh, wow should this minor the best minor here, right?
the best minor
Now I understand why it's best minor so this is the best model so far
Let's take a look on minor number 18 and it's funny though
This minor had a really good model, but it didn't catch the
Today's pattern because today is very rainy and cold day. So this is why a lot of people turn on their heaters and it wasn't
The model didn't catch it the model thought it's gonna be like it was like yesterday you see these
These spikes are here. So maybe model
This model mimics the previous behavior
Okay, and you also can you know, for example, I can take my minor and look at professor Dave's minor
And add the
Top minor number six and I just can can compare them
What's going on?
So yeah, you can take a look on this website and I think this is mostly so
We really hope that you're gonna enjoy it
you're gonna
Have fun with this because for example, I personally I'm so proud that my minor my model is
much higher
In our ranking event professor days. So hey professor. I'm waiting for you and
Also, I know that minor number six. These are really cool minor is a minor of one of our team members
His name is Matt. He's the data science genius. I would say
Okay. Other than that. I think I hope at least that you will find it fun and as well as
It will help you and your education. So good luck be creative
experiment
Try to do some cool stuff and
Enjoy it. Okay guys. Good luck with your final project and reach out to me with any questions
Okay. Bye. Bye